folks i'm going to be honest with you
this game consumed me
i consumed my life you noticed last week
there were less videos
right just because ghost of tsushima but
now it's over and i'll be honest with
you for something that consumed my life
so much
i'm actually i'm really sad it's over
it's like like over over platinum
done over i guess i have more to sniff
around you don't need to find everything
to get the platinum
well maybe that's why i'm sad because it
was so
life consuming anyhow let's talk about
it
so ghost of tsushima is it's the talk of
the town right
in terms of the video game world or at
least in the circles i
run in or at least my friends offline
in real life point is think assassin's
creed but feudal japan and that is the
plot
it's the mongol invasion of japan
starting out on this little island
called
sushima which is a real island actually
you know enough video games out there
are like
well the world's not big enough i gotta
make [ __ ] up and
make up a piece of land but no sushi is
real you play as a young samurai named
jin sakai his entire army is
wiped out and he's thought to be dead
but he's not dead
and so now you come back and you're
building up your legend and you're
helping people out and you become the
ghost of sushima with the quest to
liberate
tsushima from the mongol invaders i feel
like i really undercut it by calling it
assassin's creed but here
not that assassin's creed's bad but this
was really fun to play
first of all before i get into the
gameplay the story the story is an
epic one the villain's a dick the stakes
are high and it's not just the main
story the main story itself if you just
stick to it's not
that long but i never once thought i
could go to the end of the game without
liberating the rest of tsushima like
that's
built into the game as part of the point
so the island's broken up into three
acts three areas and as i'm going to the
end of each
area i'm just going around and
liberating the camps and the towns one
of the funnest things ever you stroll up
to this little town or camp it's like
mongol territory and you're like
oh boy leftovers just take them out
however you want but whether you're
building the story on your own
role play your own actions of liberating
people whether you're playing the main
story or the side
character stories like these side
characters become
a close member of your adopted family in
this quest
and you play their stories to the end
they're compelling they're emotional
they're heart-wrenching so as there may
be side quests
they're important for the entire feeling
and vibe of the game you can't skip
these things so whether you're doing the
main quest the side character stories or
you're just going around doing side
quests not linked to the side characters
but they're just people who need help
you know you're being a one man
seven samurai army all of it just feels
epic when it says you're building your
legend you really do
feel it you feel like you're building
the legend of the batman but
samurai you so i mean batman amurai do
not hide behind
masks
he is quite literally the hero sushima
needs
and you really feel that i'm going to
wrap back around to that in a second
because that
is tied to the gameplay which is tied to
the story and
it's all part of the experience but as
for the gameplay the gameplay is epic as
well you get four different stances not
all at once there'd be a lot of rude to
throw at you but
one stance i mean i'm i'm [ __ ] with
names i think it's actually called the
wind stance
i'll call it the triangle button that's
best for enemies with spears
circle buttons best with enemies with
shields the x button is best for enemies
with swords and the square buttons best
against brutes you know really big dudes
all important to know and remember
because yes
you go up against multiple enemies of
multiple weapon types and you have to
switch your stances on the fly as you're
fighting
multiple enemies at once which is
multi-task city and i am a [ __ ]
multi-tasker but the way the game
massages you into it
and slowly breaks you into it you know
you have one stance
then you have two then you have three
but i'm telling you by the end of this
game
you are pulling it off you're doing the
perfect counter parries slicing enemies
down all while switching between
different stances fighting multiple
types of enemies
very few games have made me feel this
badass by the end and as you do missions
and take down
mongols you get points and those upgrade
points you can put
with your stances or otherwise different
moves not just stances you have weapons
you can throw you have a bow and arrow
this i'm baffled at how many abilities
and tactics and offensive weaponry and
otherwise
ways to dispatch enemies this game gives
one character but wait there's
more you don't just have to be offensive
you know the samurai ways you know take
someone on head on so you can do that
you can do a standoff you hold the
triangle button down and you got to wait
for them to come at you and when they do
you just release it you slice them down
then you can slice a couple other
enemies you build it up so you can kind
of choose to be
the ghost you want to be do you want a
samurai take people on head-on great you
want to be a ronin an assassin
where you're like oh this isn't my first
metal gear solid game are you kidding me
hide in the shadows stealth kill enemies
you can do that too
you can do a bow and arrow which is
still in line with samurai but still
technically a stealth kill i guess if
you really think about it point is the
game lets you
build the ghost how you want to build
the ghost and that's what i'm talking
about when i say the gameplay kind of
wraps
into the story because the story being a
thick one it really deals with choice
consequence every action has a reaction
when you're an
honorable person among an honorable army
going up against an enemy that
has no honor you got to adopt new
tactics not all the samurai agree with
that you got to adapt to survive maybe
people will hate you for it in
sushima but they will be alive and free
people free to be alive
and hate you for it that's the point you
play as a character who is giving
his soul for his country and its people
that's a beautiful thing it's
it's epic and for my own personal role
play my own personal rp i had a kick
with the armor in this game
at first you know i was dressing like a
samurai i was going the samurai way then
i was dressing like a ronin you know i
was really embracing the shadows i was
the ghost
then by the end i was something
different i was this hybrid i was this
ghost of tsushima not a samurai not a
ronin something
else which is where the story leads you
but you feel like the story went there
because you did it
it's not true the story goes there
regardless but that's the point of
storytelling in a video game you're
supposed to make the player feel like
they did this and goes to sushima gave
me that feeling a lot more than a lot of
other games have but what i liked about
ghost of sushima
is i never felt like armor pieces
negated a previous armor piece your
samurai armor wasn't negated by your
ronin armor i guess you're not going to
use your samurai armor if you're going
mostly
shadow kills stealth kills and whatnot
but that's the point of the armor is
it's tailored for different gameplay
types there's alright well there is one
armor piece later on in the game that
is a lot like the ronin armor piece so
once i got that i
kind of ceased to use the ronin armor
but that's really the only one like
there are other armor pieces
i didn't use as much because it didn't
play that way the archery armor
never really used it at first i was all
just melee i just
my tactic on a lot of things is the best
defense is a good offense
until among these relics i got a certain
relic that was like if you do a head
shot with the bow and arrow it has like
a 40
chance of giving you an arrow back then
i got another relic piece that was like
if something has a percentage of odds
there's now a 50 more chance that it'll
do that then i got two of those and
point is if i shot someone in the head
i'm probably getting my arrow back but
if it all fell to [ __ ] and they spotted
me
i needed some good melee damage or at
least some good defense to keep the
fight going by that time that was pretty
good at hand-to-hand combat so but
that's my point you don't have to play
the game
through multiple times to experience the
game
multiple ways and sometimes you get
armor sets that come with helmets you're
like well i like that helmet but i like
the stats of that armor and
among the shaders that you can do you'll
probably find a shader that will
help this helmet from this armor set go
with that armor and you can just mix and
match along with the masks that really
give you the flavor you want you know to
personalize it and make it yours
some of them look pretty badass like if
i saw that dude coming after me i'd [ __ ]
myself tell me it doesn't kind of look
like the guards from the wizard of oz
oh you know it's true but as i like some
good rp
by the end i got the full armor piece
that was just the head the mask
the outfit and that was me and it felt
like mine i felt like i earned that and
i wore that to the end of the game
the game is really generous too whether
it be when you're just picking up
crafting goods you don't have to get off
your horse you can just run by it and
blank pick it up
on the go i appreciate that also really
generous with fast travel once you go to
a place and you clear out all the
mongols and now it's
it's a town where people are in or it's
liberated in some way shape or form or
you find a shrine
you can fast travel to that location at
any time i appreciate the fact that it
doesn't have
three fast travel locations and that's
that i understand some games in the
mindset of well it helps you feel like
you're in the world more it helps it
feel more real but no
it just feels overwhelming and
cumbersome thank you for the generous
fast travel also finding secrets on the
map you get your travelers gear on you
can just be like all right i want to
look for that thing and the wind will
blow you there oh
that's another thing to talk about the
wind there's no heads up display you
have to follow the wind to your location
that's not a heads up display
it's it's just the wind it just adds to
the mysticism and nature of it all you
know the spiritual energy among the lord
i just love it the one thing
that was ever an annoyance in this game
and i'm talking there's one thing
when some of these battles are going
down and the camera swings around
and puts the camera behind bushes or
trees or
other bits of debris you're like all
right i'm fighting blind right now i'm
just holding l1 praying to dear life as
if you don't have enough multitasking to
worry about in any given fight now i
gotta swing the camera around
you're getting hit now but that was
really the only real annoyance in this
game
every other element in this game
absolutely positively worked for me like
i said before a great hero the villain's
a dick the stakes are high the
characters are compelling and when it
deals with
family honor choice and consequence
everything just feels heavy it has the
explorative feeling of legend of zelda
breath of the wild
along with complex and satisfying combat
that makes you
feel as badass as the ghost of tsushima
should be
and when a game this compelling that's
this much fun
makes you feel this badass by the end
the only way to say it is
ghost of tsushima is awesome tacular
[Music]
and i cannot leave this video without
talking about kurosawa mode this
one of the reasons i could really go for
a new game plus in this game because
there's a mode called kurosawa mode
in which the game completely looks and
feels
like a game from legendary filmmaker
akira kurosawa you can pop it on at any
point in the game and i always turned it
on for a little bit and then turned it
off because i was like i want to play
the game
all the way through all with japanese
voices with english subtitles and i'm
not just uh this isn't a shader it's not
a filter to make the game look kind of
different
it makes the game fundamentally feel
completely different i have no doubt
this game was inspired by kurosawa
so they didn't have to have this mode in
here but the fact that they
did and it's a mode that so completely
changes the vibe of the game
it's not just fan service it's above and
beyond i gotta give them props for
including this mode alright so ghost of
sushima have you played it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you